you
so particle physicists we're trying to
understand sub structure of matter
what's really out there what's at the
core it matter how it interacts what are
the fundamental forces and as you go to
deeper and deeper skills you've learned
different things so there's sort of
two-pronged approach there's some very
theoretical work that goes on and this
some very experimentally oriented work
we're trying to see what we can find out
at the collider that we'll turn on again
next week we hope the collider that
we'll be running for the next couple of
years the Large Hadron Collider that
will collide together protons at high
energy and tell us what's out there we
also try to combine it together with
theoretical ideas we've been working on
some of them generated from more
high-energy theoretical ideas beyond
what we can see with experiment and
we're trying to put those together on a
day to day basis we could be thinking
about many different things we could be
thinking about what the experiments will
do it could be thinking about the
theoretical ideas how they fit together
doing the calculations to see what the
consequences of some ideas which we call
models would be there might be some
speculations or hypotheses for what's
out there and we try to derive what the
consequences would be in tests whether
those ideas works test these ideas that
might synthesize some of the various
phenomena that we've observed but we
don't yet understand
so the LHC stands for large hadron
collider it's large it's 27 kilometers
in circumference it's a big tunnel where
two beams of protons will circulate
around and then collide at various
points within that tunnel when it
collides it will collide together at
high energy I'm about seven times the
energy of the highest energy Collider
we've yet had on earth and when we when
it does that the idea is for the mass of
the particles converts into energy that
energy aren't worthy sorry describe that
the energy that's created in the
collision can then convert into new
particles those particles can have
heavier mass than anything that's been
created before
v equals MC squared so having bigger
energy means that we can create
particles that have bigger mass um it
also will have what's called high
luminosity which is to say there's a
high collision rate so the hope is that
by having these new parameters this new
this high rate of collision these high
energies will be able to study matter in
ways we haven't been able to study it
before in the process we want to
understand the answers to questions like
where did the masses of fundamental
particles come from that might sound
like an odd question since math seems
like an intrinsic property to matter but
it turns out that in the simplest
versions of the theories you write down
particles don't have mass and we know
that it's actually only possible for
particles to have mass because of
something like a phase transition that
happened in the early universe something
called the Higgs mechanism named after
the physicist Peter Higgs who thought of
it and the idea is that particles at
high energy might seem not to have mass
but at low energies they do and the
question is how did they come about if
it's a simple Higgs mechanism
implementation we'll find something
called the Higgs boson it's a particle
that tells us that this is really what
happens and really puts it all together
the standard model works to an
incredibly high degree of precision we
believe it's right this Dana model of
particle physics tells us what are the
basic elements of matter what are the
forces through which they interact it's
been tested to a high degree of
precision but it doesn't answer
questions like where did the particle
masses come from the elementary particle
masses come from and the other question
is as an answer is why are those masses
about the scale that they are why aren't
those messes much bigger that has to do
something what we call the hierarchy
problem a particle
which is connected to the question of
why gravity is so weak and those are the
types of questions we hope to answer at
the LHC if we're really lucky we might
also get some insight into dark matter
the matter that doesn't emit light that
we know is out there in the universe so
there's a number of questions that we
hope the LHC might help us answer
as far as dark matter goes we could be
lucky in the sense that it seems that if
you look at just the amount of dark
matter that's out there in the universe
we can we can figure out what that
what's called the relic density is given
a certain type of interaction that is to
say how much stuff should be left over
now that the universe is big and cool
and it turns out that if particles have
mass about the scale is going to be
probed at the LHC the Large Hadron
Collider that it turns out to have about
the right relic density now this might
be just a coincidence or it might be
something deep and fundamental telling
us that the Large Hadron Collider might
actually be able to produce the Dark
Matter particle it might not produce it
directly but it could produce something
that decays into the dark matter
particles so there is some hope that by
proving this energy that the LHC will
study we can learn something about dark
matter
you